While less than 2% of the human genome
actually counts as coding for anything, there are
more than 20,000 genes in just that 2%.
Now we refer to this major division in the
genome as protein coding DNA and non-coding DNA.
Now the rest of this lesson will actually continue
to cover how this 2% of our genome
still codes for all those proteins. The next lesson
will actually start to reveal some more about the role of this 98% of non-coding
DNA. To make sure that your understanding of
non-coding and protein coding DNA sequences is clear,
I've listed five different types of sequence that we could find in a genome. We
have exons, introns, promoter regions, translated sequence between
start and stop codons, and untranslated sequence that
would be transcribed but outside start and stop codons. I want
you to indicate which sequences is in this list here. Which
sequences of DNA would be considered either coding or non-coding. So
we're going to use the number one to represent coding and
two to represent non-coding. So in each box I want you
to put either the number one or the number two to
indicate whether an exon would be considered part of coding or
non-coding sequence. Go ahead and pick which answer you think is
best for each item in the list.